antoine 21 ans est hémiplégique veut
s'inscrire à une course de 10 km contre
l'avis de son médecin de l'organisateur
et de sa famille c'est le héros du court
métrage second souffre de lucas renault
qui a nécessité six jours de tournage
une équipe de 40 personnes et 50
figurants ce court métrage parle de du
combat contre la considération des
autres qui est souvent mauvais sens
faite par rapport à regard que nous
avons sur nous mêmes et donc de
l'émancipation en fait de ce regard là
surtout que le regard des autres c'est
ce qui nous construit et donc en fait
vivre avec un regard négatif sur nous ça
a forcément un impact sur notre propre
conception de ce que nous sommes aidés
par la fondation mallet la ccpa chez le
producteur jean marc auclair ce court
métrage qui fait écho à une histoire
personnelle porte un véritable message
d'espoir c'est son bras gauche
non maga turquie se fasse alors quoi on
savait n'est pas paralysé non plus mais
ça va je peux le faire
mon chéri tu es né avec ton handicap
c'est normal que tu te rendent plus
compte ce personnage me ressemble au
point où nous avons les mêmes
difficultés physiques donc elite
hémiplégique que tout comme moi nous
avons eu également un avc à la naissance
cet avc m'a justement construit et que
ça fait ce que ce que je suis
aujourd'hui et quand même si si j'ai
souvent pensé que c'était un fardeau que
c'était vraiment très compliqué et c'est
là je me dis que
content d'avoir eu cette expérience
entre guillemets au début de ma vie
parce que je suis sûr que ça va me
servait en fait tout au long mais si
cette course que je veux faire
je l'avais s'il est derrière moi depuis
longtemps j'ai juste besoin d'avancer un
peu
j'en ai marre qu'on met des barrières
tout le temps
je vais y arriver des images tournées à
richebourg en yvelines les paysages de
son enfance ses des lieux forcément que
je que je connais depuis mon enfance
parce que je vis à richebourg depuis
depuis maintenant 20 ans donc forcément
c'est des lieux que je connais par coeur
j'ai l'habitude de venir courir ici
pratiquement tous les jours un court
métrage qui doit maintenant se faire une
place il a deux ans pour se faire un nom
dans les festivals avant d'enfin pouvoir
être diffusés au grand public